So I was reading the headline this morning.
I didn't read the entire article because the
headline was self explanatory.
And you'll understand in a moment.
I was reading the headline about Donald Trump's
visit to the UK and it said that the, uh,
the Prince Prince Charles spent an entire
hour alone with Donald Trump trying to convince
him that client climate change was real and
that climate science was real and, uh, and
was a genuine threat to civilization.
And Donald Trump's response was simply that,
you know, don't blame America for climate
change.
Now I want you to take a moment and go with
me is I juxtapose that idiocy with this article
that the, uh, that ABC News reported this
morning saying that climate change could end
human civilization by 20.
I want to read a couple of quotes from the
article quoting the paper published by the
Australian think tank last week gives one
scenario in which by 2050 accelerating climate
change impacts pose large negative consequences
which might not be undone for centuries.
And went on to say there is broad scientific
acceptance that tipping points for the West
Antarctic ice sheet and the uh, seat ice free
Arctic summer, we'll pass well before one
point, uh, well before 1.5 degrees Celsius
of warming.
According to the report, the Greenland ice
sheet will melt well before two degrees Celsius
of warming.
And then widespread permafrost laws and large
scale drought in the Amazon will occur by
2.5 degrees of warming.
And, and not to just read the entire article,
but I, I really, I really want to take a moment
and put it into context.
Um, but you, you, you have to this next, this
next line is important.
Listen, quote, even with two degrees Celsius
of warming, there's a high likelihood of human
civilization coming to an end according to
the report.
Um, the only thing, the only thing in this
article that, that really sticks out to me
is the, is the fact that there is broad scientific
acceptance as well as consensus that this
is happening.
And yet we have one half of our two party
system that is completely dedicated to undermining
the science and doing so for not only political
purposes, but primarily for economic purposes,
uh, serving their real constituents, which
is the energy sector.
I'm not wanting to make any moves that would
damage the oil industry or the auto industry
or any industries, uh, or, or, or, or the,
um, big meat industry, right?
Uh, any industry that is remotely connected
to a, exacerbating the problems of climate
change, they don't want to do anything on
those because they're getting donations from
those industries.
It's really that simple.
But it's also that said that we are facing
this, this existential crisis that we have
clear understanding over that we see happening.
We see, we see ships in our climate happening
now.
We see wild swings in weather happening right
More tornadoes recorded in the last 30 days.
Uh, a record number of tornadoes recorded
in the last 30 days.
It's, they're just, it's not only the scientific
fact that, that we see it coming, it's the
fact that we can, it, it's starting to occur,
but you end compound that you add insult to
injury when you have so much of our political
system committed to undermining this one thing.
And it's like, you know, out of all the things
that we could argue about that are, you know,
important.
Yes.
But they're not, they're not going to be,
it's not going to be the end of civilization
if we don't get medicare for all right.
Or if we politicize medicare for all for the
next 30 years, you know, don't get me wrong.
I need, and we want Medicare for all, but
it's not an existential crisis for human civilization.
So I get the political Kabuki theater, the
games that we play around some political issues.
Uh, it's a horse race.
It's a game, but there's certain, I mean,
if there's a meteor coming to the planet,
you know, and we see it coming and there's
something that we could do about it.
You know, there's no, there's no politicization
of that.
And if anybody actually wants to politicize
that, then we need to drag them out into the
streets and, um, you know, have a conversation
with them about politics.
You know, I, I gotta, I gotta remember this
is all this actually public radio.
So, uh, but, but you get the point, right?
There's some things that we could play with.
There's some things that we can argue about
and play with is not the right phrase, but
argue over.
But, but the, the, an existential crisis that
could be the end of human civilization and
to, I mean, I, I mean, we don't even have
to dramaticized this, right?
It's happening.
We see it happening.
The data shows is happening.
But there's a level of frustration when you're
looking at a person who knows good and well
that, that the science is saying that climate
change is occurring and that we're getting
close to a tipping point, a point of no return.
And now this latest report is saying that
it could end, that it could end civilization
by 2050.
And this is, let me read one more paragraph,
one more paragraph, because I think you can
understand why this, why this is not so much
hyperbole.
They said, quote, the warming will also bring
more than 20 days annually of lethal heat
conditions beyond the threshold of human survivability.
Scientists report deadly.
He conditions will persist for more than 100
days a year in west Africa, tropical South
America, the Middle East and South Asia, which
would displace more than a billion people
from those areas.
So we're not talking about necessarily a,
an existential crisis.
And in terms of like a movie, you know, people
are going to dismiss this video and so many
other, in so many other conversations, because
they try to, uh, they, they basically Straw
manual.
I'm like, oh, there's not going to be a wave
that comes in, destroys everybody in civilization
is over.
No.
So the way this works is that when you have
1 billion displaced people, you have a situation
that undermines the stability of every government,
of every institution, every supply chain,
every food chain.
I mean, everything that makes our system work.
When you have 1 billion people strategically
placed, not the correct word, but you understand
what I'm saying, like, like placed in every
region of the globe.
There's not going to be a place on the face
of the planet that has not affected by this
displacement of 1 billion people.
And there's not really a place on the planet
that can absorb that number of people and
still have a sustainable model.
And so when we say the end of civilization,
we're not talking about mass extinction yet.
We're talking about the fact that our systems
and our institutions will not be able to handle
the mass displacement of billions of people
occurring at the same time because of the
conditions that we joke about today, that
we, that the Republicans think is a game that,
that they blame and say, ah, they blamed God
up for it and they say, Oh God, we'll take
it, you know, all the stupid things that are
said to undermine the, uh, the fight against
climate change.
Um, it's a level of seriousness, especially
when you have kids like, you know, 2050, I'll
be 70, 70 years old.
Um, so maybe I'll still be here, but you know,
hopefully my kids will be young still.
But I digress.